I'm Jack Rollins I'm the neighborhood
superintendent for Camden and I'm here
to read you a statement about the
incident that happened yesterday
just before 1 30 PM yesterday we were
called to reports of a shooting outside
Saint Aloysius Church in Phoenix Road
Camden
officers responded with paramedics and a
crew from the London air ambulance
they found multiple people with injuries
caused by pellets from a shotgun
four women aged 21 41 48 and 54 were
taken to Central London hospitals where
thankfully their injuries were assessed
as non-life-threatening
the 48 year old woman has sustained
potentially life-changing injuries
two children were also injured
a 12 year old girl sustained a leg
injury
she was treated at hospital before being
discharged yesterday afternoon she is
expected to make a full recovery
a seven-year-old girl was more seriously
injured
she remains in a house in in hospital in
a stable but life-threatening conditions
and our thoughts are with her and her
family
the incident took place as mourners
gathered outside the church following a
funeral
we believe the suspects discharged a
shotgun from a moving vehicle
which was a black Toyota CHR
likely a 2019 model or similar
this was a shocking incident
people came here to attend a funeral to
be with friends and loved ones and mourn
together instead they were the victims
of a senseless act of violence
we know it would have had a significant
impact on communities across Camden and
we will have a visible police presence
in the local area in the coming days and
weeks to provide extra reassurance and
as your neighborhood superintendent I
will assure that will be happening
I can promise that we are doing
everything we can to identify and bring
to Justice those who are responsible for
this attack
the investigation is being led by the
Mets specialist crime command
we have a significant number of
specialist detectives and local officers
working around the clock but we also
need the Public's help
we want to hear from anyone who
witnessed the incident or has
information about it
your information could be vitally
important no matter how insignificant
you think it is
please call the Metropolitan Police on
one zero one or Crime Stoppers
anonymously on 0800 triple five triple
one
thank you very much